my concern with people who are a coach
and they're really proud of their tough
love approach is that i just think it's
usually not the best approach
and
you know there are ways to deliver
truthful statements um
that you know have less than than or or
deliver feedback that's not favorable
you know there might be areas where you
have to say hey we really need to
improve on this you can deliver those
truths without being abrasive
and if you look into some of the
research on self-determination theory uh
that research would indicate that
uh the abrasive approach uh probably is
not doing a lot to support that
athlete's success in the long term so
i i do kind i i find it a little bit
amusing that there are a lot of people
who are like
you know they're evidence-based coaches
and they're proud of it and they tell
you all the time i'm evidence-based and
they mock people for being out of step
with the nutrition literature or the
exercise literature
but their actual job is coaching and
they are fully out of step with the
coaching literature you know like like
they are missing an entire field of
science that would make them better at
it well there
there is a more cynical interpretation
which is so when you say
you think tough love isn't a good
approach the question you then need to
ask yourself is a good approach for who
um
you know and is is that going to be the
optimal approach to
um
improve the results for that particular
client versus is that the optimal
approach to
improve the profitability of your
coaching program
and i think that for
uh some percentage of coaches
i
i don't think people are actually like
sitting down and thinking through this
but i think that
you maybe notice trends over time where
uh clients who respond well to that
tough love approach
where essentially what you're saying as
a coach is like hey here's the decision
you need to make
and that's that's 100 on you and if you
make this decision where you are going
to
do
all of the things you need to do to
reach your goals without me reminding
you or without us having ongoing
conversations about this stuff
uh
you know you'll probably get good
results and you're gonna be a very low
effort client for me uh versus you know
a more collaborative approach where
there's more conversations that take
place
you know more little trade-offs you talk
about on a more frequent basis
that may
improve the odds on a per-client basis
of client success but it's also
increasing the weekly workload per
client and so i think i think some
percentage of coaches uh
maybe subconsciously realize that that
tough love approach uh increases the
size of a roster that they can maintain
by by weeding out
people who are like truly driven and
want to have success but may take a
little bit more effort for the coach to
help them get there um
yeah i mean
i
agree i agree with your statement that
tough love may not be the best approach
if maximizing per client odds of success
is the end point you care about the most
yeah but i don't necessarily know that
that is a true assumption for everyone
all the time well that's because you
didn't take the road to enlightenment
you know you have all that cynicism
built up and yeah
yeah you're definitely correct uh
unfortunately um but
one day i will do a segment on
self-determination theory and get more
into the details but when you look into
that research this whole tough love
approach um usually
you'll see things dichotomized sometimes
as autonomy supporting behaviors of a
coach versus controlling behaviors of a
coach autonomy supporting behaviors are
fantastic they empower the client and
and really
favorably impact a number of positive
psychological outcomes controlling
behaviors really chip away at the root
of self-determination theory and leave
clients in a position where their
psychological needs are not being met
and their long-term success is far less
likely
so tough love kind of checks quite a few
of the boxes for these controlling
behaviors that based on literally
like all of the psychology research and
the coaching research
can lead to some pretty unfavorable
long-term outcomes and just really
detract from the well-being and the
enjoyment of the client